she had made a promise with garrett cole
when she interviewed him when he was the
pirate she said you'd be a great yankee
and if you ever become a yankee i
promise i'll sing the national anthem on
opening day so she fulfilled her promise
she nailed it too the yankees banging on
some drums here and along with the red
sox honoring all those first responders
who have worked so hard to bring the
city back to where it needs to be our
guests spent 11 seasons in pinstripes
throwing out tonight's ceremonial first
pitch c
c
sabathia thank you cece
nice comeback story for jordan
montgomery who missed the entire 2019
season saved just
two appearances one start recovering
from tommy john surgery a year ago makes
him fish on a pitch in the dirt jordan
montgomery's got himself the strikeout
so one gone for montgomery and now it's
the designated hitter jd martinez
there's a little bouncer for dj lemay
two gun for a left-handed hitter now
rafael devers and he puts one in play
for the first baseman luke floyd it's a
very quick comeback inning for jordan
montgomery these yankees taking swings
against the 29 year old veteran
right-hander ryan weber it's gonna have
to be very precise control picture and a
ground ball for devers to start the day
for ryan weber here's aaron judge homer
yesterday bounce to shortstop for
bogards
and a good start to the day so far for
weber with a couple of ground balls
on the ground for bogarts three ground
ball outs no damage done in the home
half of the first giovanni or shellac i
don't know if i can think of a greater
transformation story than the guy that's
at the plate right now well hit to right
center field bradley back leaps and
makes a fine catch at the wall
absolutely
wrong person so the tattoos walk of the
inning by weber being understandably
careful with this power pack lineup
nagashioka with the ground ball to
shortstop bogart's been busy to start
the game and once again weber fades a
couple of base runners jordan montgomery
perfect six up six down in his first
start in about a year michael chavis
leads things off for boston michael
chavis cracks open the scoreboard with a
long one
first of the year for chavis
hit 18 as a rookie last season one
nothing boston that's when you scratch
your head because the pitch selection
and the execution were right there's jd
martinez now with a run in two runners
aboard and only one god
and martinez into right center where he
gets his power but this one not well hit
judge is able to make the catch and
double off
wow not quite sure where kevin pollard
was headed a 9-3 double play the red sox
had the makings of the beginning goes
away on a line drive to right and dj le
mayhew has a lead off single the
opposite field power hitters in this
matchup and judges is one of the big
names in that group oh my goodness aaron
judge to right and well hit bradley back
no bringing this one home
a two-run shot for aaron judge right
where he likes it it's a two-to-one
yankee lead on the aaron judge homer's
third of the year bradley
into the beverage advertising without
being able to escape that one just snuck
right past montgomery's glove a routine
play
that will no doubt be scored as an error
and will load the bases big opportunity
for michael chavis who homered back in
the third
sharply hit to third orcella to le
mayhew back to point they double them
off in and out of trouble in the fourth
giovanna your shell of red gardner kyle
higashioka the bottom third of the
yankee order big drive out to right fire
shella and that one's gonna go the
yankees are so comfortable sitting there
knowing they can't get beat on a
fastball knowing right field is about
150 feet away that's what it seems like
to them jordan montgomery who's given a
sixth ending of work tonight with the
exception of the chavis home run no
damage tonight on the ground sharply hit
for lemay here to torres for one a
double play jordan montgomery who last
worked on a big league mound over a year
ago has to be nothing but pleased
runners at first and second for aaron
judge
three pitches takes care of judge and
it's another scoreless inning by
phillips valdez who strands a pair
stands aboard with one gun and now aaron
hicks bats with the man on swinging to
miss with the runner going throw down to
second a strike amount throw him out
double play to retire the side and
there's a one out base runner in scoring
position so now brett gardner this is
the kind of night then at some point for
a guy who is still looking for his first
base hit you got to think you're getting
close
there it is
first hit of the year is a two-run home
run
jonathan holder will look to send this
one into the official column and he's
got a four-run lead to work with back up
the middle right for torres to retire
the side and end the proceedings tonight
all yankees a michael chavis home run
may have started the scoring but five
unanswered by new york all of them
coming on the power of home runs